non-minimalists
how do you strike a balance between
loving and accepting yourself for who
you are but also striving to better
yourself for example reducing addictions
stopping bad habits or losing weight
well no um man i just want to say stop
trying to be better
yeah i think one of the problems is we
we presuppose that
doing something to make us better is
actually going to make us better but it
often covers up the problem that is
deeper and so we do all of these
superficial things all of the the things
that appear like they're going to
improve our lives the self-improvement
but we're not actually improving the
self we're improving the circumstances
that surround the self but often those
circumstances
are making us miserable well um the way
that i would attack this question is by
using an analogy
so let's think about either a walkathon
or a marathon
26.2 miles
if you've ever run one
you know that the most incredible part
of doing a walkathon
or a marathon are all of the spectators
along the side cheering for you
and high-fiving you every step of the
way
if you've ever been a spectator at a
walk-a-thon or a marathon you know that
the energy is infectious yeah we don't
stand at mile seven and go
you're not done yet
boy you're you're running slow right
hurry up clapping to you you know until
you get there
and we'll see what your time looks like
maybe that like that's not what we do no
we empower people to push through
their limitations mentally and
physically
by raising our hands and high-fiving
them and transferring our belief to them
yeah and what i'm here to say is we have
been overwhelmed by the number of people
the day we published the book
somebody wrote to us and said i was in a
church basement at an a.a meeting and
somebody stood up and said i have been
practicing something called the high
five habit i watch this woman on youtube
i am telling you everybody we all need
to get on the bandwagon
i am shedding shame
one high five at a time
and one of the reasons why people stay
stuck
is because they're trying to do the
things that change their lives while
still judging the hell out of themselves
for where they've been or where they are
and so i believe again i sound like a
broken record because this is so
foundational
that if you do want to manage addiction
if you do want to
change your habits if you do want to
improve your life you will not do it by
criticizing where you are because
research shows it's demotivating you
will not do it by beating yourself up
you will change the same way a marathon
runner finishes a race because your life
is a marathon
and there will be legs of that mile that
are extraordinarily difficult where you
want to quit and your knees are buckling
and you your your
why did i sign up and i got blisters and
i should just stop it and it will be the
slap of a stranger's hand
that sign of encouragement that sign of
belief that keeps you going you must
start practicing the high five habit
because even if you don't ever do those
things
to change your life
you will change how you feel about
yourself and that changes your life and
that's yeah that's the best way to
change your life yeah is to feel
different about yourself because also if
you're always trying to be better oh if
i just lost weight i'd be better if i
just wrote that play i'd be better if i
just did x y or z i'd be better you're
training yourself to always look for the
next thing rather than accept you for
who you are right and you're
invalidating where you are which makes
you less motivated to do anything new
yeah and so if you validate where you
are
okay i may have let it go
i may be having trouble with this sober
thing
i may have a lot of regrets but by god i
see you and we're going to try again
today
that's what that says and that sends you
into your day
physiologically neurologically
different
and that is what will motivate you to do
the hard things to say no thanks i'll
take the seltzer
yeah yeah did you enjoy this video if so
you can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel one
hundred percent advertisement free